bienvenidos a esta edición especial de
fondos hoy en y pérez se que en berlín
jornada electoral de infarto para
definir el futuro político de alemania
sin angela merkel olaf scholz el
candidato del partido socialdemócrata es
el vencedor de los comicios y la se
debut de hamit light el partido
conservador de angela merkel ha quedado
en segundo lugar luego de una derrota
histórica y sin embargo también quiere
formar gobierno
el spd y la cdu por lo tanto tendrán que
negociar en separado con los otros dos
partidos más pequeños en juego los
verdes y los liberales del fdp se habrá
si el poker político para gobernar en
alemania tras una de las selecciones más
imprevisibles de las últimas décadas en
la mayor economía de europa por eso en
esta edición especial de a fondo nos
preguntamos alemania sin merkel como
sigue la historia
[Música]
y sean ustedes muy bienvenidos a esta
edición especial de a fondo con motivo
de las elecciones del bundestag 2021 soy
en y pérez en berlín para deutsche dl
nos acompañan hoy
esther herrera periodista de france 24
corresponsal experta en política europea
de la cadena pública francesa en
bruselas según esther europa tendrá que
esperar para decidir sobre cuestiones
urgentes ante una alemania que tendrá
dice tiempo en formar gobierno
buscar virgen periodista de radio
experto en política semana europea y
transatlántica para buscar los
cristianos demócratas son los perdedores
de estos comicios sin embargo el nuevo
gobierno de alemania lo definirán dos
partidos minoritarios dice los verdes y
los liberales y francos de letona
experto comunicación política y creador
del podcast el fin de la era merkel
track opina que esta elección deja un
escenario que se contrapone con lo que
ha sido la era merkel
incertidumbre
y la de hoy es una edición especial
conjunta con el canal público francés
france 24 para poner también en
perspectiva los resultados de estas
elecciones escribano por favor su
opinión a fondo arroba de w puntocom o
comenté a través de nuestra publicación
en youtube anímense siempre nos
alegramos de sus comentarios comenzamos
inmediatamente porque hay mucho que
comentar y quiero partir en primer lugar
por nuestra invitada stern fue una de
las jornadas electorales decíamos más
impredecibles que nos haya tocar
observar y también informar cómo valoras
tú lo que pasó este domingo y en
alemania bueno yo sobre todo creo que ha
sido una jornada muy interesante en que
alemania que siempre había sido como una
isla de estabilidad a todo el mundo daba
por hecho con unos sondeos que al final
fueron más ajustados de lo que se
esperaba con el spd con la cdu y los
socialistas y por lo tanto de una
jornada muy interesante con mucha
atención a europa estaba muy muy
pendiente de la jornada de ayer y él te
presto a ti francos de leona que está
perdido un poco quizás ésta está esa
estabilidad cuando vemos sobre todo las
votaciones concentra principalmente las
dos grandes fuerzas políticas que han
gobernado
spd y cdu y concretamente que podemos
decir del vencedor hasta ahora
de los resultados el spd de la
socialdemocracia en alemania sí yo creo
que lo que sea lo que ha cambiado un
poco es el tema de la certidumbre porque
hasta hace unos años si estaban que la
marca de todo el mundo sabía que iba a
gobernar angela merkel con alguien más y
ahora no sabemos bien qué va a pasar
ahora si miramos a los socialdemócratas
podemos decir que son ganadores no diría
grandes ganadores de la jornada pero sí
se impusieron lograron un punto y pico
por encima de sus competidores y creo
que eso le puede dar una posición de
ventaja a la hora de seguir no y esa
socialdemocracia ahora tiene esta
posibilidad de volver luego de tanto
tiempo a tener esa ese protagonismo que
de alguna manera se le había ido hacía
en las últimas elecciones
y tú dices que el gran perdedor de las
jornadas y de la cdu de angela merkel
con arm y blazer en la cabeza y te
pregunto yo en verdad bueno como es que
es posible que hayamos llegado a este
resultado ahora mismo son casi nueve
puntos abajo
sí porque el cdu los cristianodemócratas
y los cristianos sociales en baviera han
perdido su perfil no tienen perfil y
porque no tienen perfil porque angela
merkel era la mejor socialdemócrata de
este gobierno y en un lapso como los
alemanes son conservadores de por sí y
no quieren aventuras ahora scholtz
incorporó la continuación de la guerra
merkel era tintes vicecanciller yo creo
que eso jugó mucho a su favor y además
la gente estaba cansado del cd&v
facebook 16 años en el poder pero si te
entiendo bien si entonces la
socialdemocracia le debe el éxito a la
política de merkel entonces la feu le
debe la derrota
interesante franco si a mí me parece
interesante esto que plantea de la
socialdemocratización de merkel que
siempre se discute y la verdad que me
gusta verlo más como como que merkel
logró modernizar a la sede uno que
adaptó a la cdu a los tiempos tal vez
con temas de familia por ejemplo con
varias cuestiones que obviamente venían
de esa agenda socialdemócrata y ahí es
donde se produce ese tema la cuestión es
que es cierto que la cdu al tener esta
adaptación pierde ese perfil y no lo
puede reconstruir tan rápido porque
porque se recuestan en la figura de
merkel si con markel ganamos todas las
elecciones entonces eso de alguna manera
no termina por tener sustancia después y
es lo que vemos ahora que merkel siempre
aportaba diez puntos pues cuando se le
preguntaba a la gente si no estuviesen
merkel usted votaría había diez puntos
de la sedue que decía no votaría a otro
partido bueno esos diez puntos se lo
llevó en gran parte olaf scholz ahí sí
podemos decir que ganó otra parte más
chica se la llevaron los verdes después
podemos discutir porque no más de lo que
se creía y una parte se quedó con la cdu
pero la verdad que no lo suficiente para
poder imponerse hay otros dos partidos
que han ganado votaciones solo ahora los
sobran los grandes partidos condenados a
conformar coaliciones de gobierno que
son los liberales y los verdes vamos a
hablar de aquello después quiero
detenerme contigo franco brevemente por
favor es lo que le ha pasado al partido
populista derecha alternativa para
alemania diez puntos se alcanzaron y
significa un gran retroceso en verdad de
la de la tercera fuerza política pasan a
la cuenta que le dice esto a alemania
bueno ya este partido también que en
realidad aparte de sumar una victoria en
sax en no suma más si igual que hay
matizar yo un poco yo no sé si es una
gran derrota no sé si es tan terrible la
situación de ellos es verdad perdieron
puntos es verdad la situación interna
del partido es mala tiene un problema
con la justicia o sea hay muchas cosas
que están pasando ahí tiene una interna
muy fuerte y pese a todo eso sacan 10
puntos me parece que significa por un
lado consolidan un electorado mucha
gente habla de que alemania se normaliza
en el sentido de que tiene una derecha
radical
esta vía está hábil digamos en el
sistema de partidos y lo otro que tienen
que tal vez no se ve tanto en los
resultados pero que es muy importante al
tener dos legislaturas consecutivas van
a recibir fondos para sus fundaciones
políticas y tiene una cantidad de enero
muy importante para poder formar cuadros
digamos para profesionalizar el partido
no y también política inferior no
también para hacer política exterior a
propósito de eso esther nuestra colega
de france 24 ya hace un rato también que
los franceses fueron a las urnas y como
se electoralmente que conformado esa
situación con la el partido de populista
de derecha en francia también en europa
que nos dice lo que está pasando hoy día
con la ultraderecha en alemania con
estos ocho partidos que fueron tan
exitosos hace hace dos tres cuatro años
bueno es cierto lo que dice el franco
tiene toda la razón es verdad que bueno
si ha perdido un cierto ímpetu igual la
fd pero sí que es cierto que está para
quedarse la extrema derecha en europa
vemos el reagrupamiento nacional
liderado por marine le pen en los
últimos sondeos parecía que había bajado
un poquito pero no lo suficiente según
los pronósticos en la segunda ronda de
las presidenciales en las elecciones
de la próxima primavera se prevé un
escenario emanuel macrón marie le pen en
segunda ronda de nuevo es decir la
extrema derecha la verdad es que está
lamentablemente bien asentada en europa
vemos el partido box en españa por
ejemplo que ha sido clave en elecciones
regionales tanto en madrid como en
andalucía luego vemos a polonia el
partido la injusticia que gobierna muy
cómodamente en el país la extrema
derecha está muy cómoda en él en todo
caso diez puntos de apoyo que sigue
teniendo un electorado convencido dice
franco de león y sin embargo es un
partido que tiene muy poca votación o
mucho retroceso en el oeste pero que
recibe apoyos en el este me pregunto yo
se convierte a efe de que estas
elecciones en un partido del este
sí parece porque es el partido más
fuerte en touring ahí en saxonia más
fuerte que el pse de buque después de
que los partidos tradicionales y ahí sí
hay una división entre este y oeste en
alemania claramente de la gente
frustrada pero yo hubiera pensado que
con la pandemia y la crítica del manejo
de la pandemia a la vez te hubiera
recogido más votos aún pero el retroceso
había un retroceso de votos eso ya es
algo positivo y también quedó fuerte
porque la crisis de los cristianos
demócratas no ofrece nada a los al
electorado conservador y eso es siempre
ha sido la política de famosos
cristianos sociales o cristianos
demócratas que a la derecha del cde
usted es un no debe haber partido a
espacio para un partido o sea yo creo
que el cdu se va a reformar en un
sentido depende se va a entrar el
gobierno o no pero si se quedará en la
oposición se tendrá o se va a reformar
con una tendencia más conservadora a ver
esto es lo que pasó con los populistas
de derecha de qué pasa con dell inc que
es un partido la izquierda poscomunista
que realmente si no fuera por esos tres
mandatos directos estaría fuera del boom
de esta que le dice esto también a estas
elecciones de la clase política alemana
y a los alemanes o sea los alemanes van
a puestos nuevamente en estas elecciones
por el centro yo creo que después de no
quiere decir que sí están por el centro
es cierto pero se reordena el centro no
es el mismo centro que hace un tiempo
los dos partidos mayoritarios son muy no
sé si lo podemos llevar mayoritarios
ahora pero en términos de su tamaño pero
aparecen los otros dos que ya dijimos
liberales y verdes que son las llaves
para la gobernanza de alguna manera y
con di link que creo que lo que pasó es
que sufrieron fuertemente el crecimiento
del spe de la mayoría de los votos
cuando no ve el trasvase van hacia allá
también perdieron un poco hacia asia
verdes incluso hacia liberales es decir
la la sangría va para todos lados en ese
partido tiene un problema también de
liderazgo no los líderes más conocidos
hicieron su campaña por su cuenta se
separaron un poco de ese nuevo liderazgo
que tenía el partido y creo que eso le
jugó en contra en todo sentido y ya
después de tanto tiempo de haber sido
creado no son más el partido antisistema
el partido que se podía votar para
protestar etcétera y dónde está eran más
fuertes en el este aparece a este no sé
exactamente a la vez que ha tomado el
lugar del link que no para ese electoral
que está frustrado que vota en contra no
dillinger claro también se ha puesto
fuera de juego con uno para
sacar la gente del afganistán con la
otan con la política exterior y hubiera
sido de todas forma muy muy improbable
que al despedir los verdes se hubiera
alcanzado los números hubiesen formado
una coalición de izquierda con ellos
pero también es verdad que el eslogan
del clima que ellos también impulsaban
era prácticamente el mismo sino el mismo
de los verdes
política social la misma del sitio de
que se solapan los temas entonces a
quién vota si votas por clima vota salud
verde no a dillinger no delinque cosas y
como decíamos que la sede pierde perfil
del link que también en este tiempo
pierde cierto perfil se pierde la
izquierda se pierde también hace de
perder la mitad de los votos por lo
menos si eso que le dice a europa que le
dice a francia es tener los resultados
estas elecciones inequívocamente decimos
es una política es que quien sea quien
va a conformar el próximo gobierno y
como sea es el centrista eso alivia a
europa a libia francia sin todas las
elecciones de hoy sin duda al final los
que los posibles
candidatos a poder llegar a la
cancillería realmente son pre europeos
entonces europa lo que necesita es
estabilidad luego claro no sé que se
puede entender bien bien con estabilidad
porque hay que esperar bastante tiempo
parece ser para que se pueda formar
gobierno en alemania y ahora mismo la
unión europea tiene asuntos muy urgentes
que tratar como cuáles clima hablemos de
nuevos clima está el presidente ma norma
como si tenemos un paquete que hay que
aprobar el fit for fifty five que es una
legislación enorme para reducir el 55
por ciento de emisiones de aquí a 2030
según los valores de 1990 y lo cierto es
que hay que ser muy rápido porque en
nueve años hay que reducirlo y es un
paquete muy ambicioso y hay que
aprobarlo por otra parte y hasta ahora
alemania ha arrancado un poco con esta
cuestión es uno de los países que más
emite dióxido de carbono de la unión
europea por lo tanto ahí tiene un
verdadero problema luego está la
cuestión de afganistán con esta posible
crisis migratoria se va a producir lo
mismo
2016 aquí también hay dudas y por
supuesto relación transatlántica y china
son cuestiones muy urgentes vamos a
hablar eeuu rusia tiene también más
adelante por ahora queremos detenernos
en lo que veíamos este domingo dos
hombres acapararon la atención de la
jornada electoral en alemania y ambos
tienen posibilidades de ser el próximo
canciller de alemania pero mientras el
socialdemócrata olaf scholz agradecía
con entusiasmo el mayor apoyo en digamos
digamos la haber ganado las elecciones
finalmente con sus votantes un
complicado al mislata se trataba de
salvar la indiscutible derrota del
partido la cdu vamos a escuchar a ambos
candidatos
bofill y me alegro de ver tanta gente y
por supuesto del apoyo recibido por el
electorado que ha permitido subir al
partido social-demócrata en todos los
aspectos es un gran éxito
pero que muchos electores quieren un
cambio en el gobierno y que el próximo
canciller se llame hola
espero es más
todo apunta a que por primera vez podría
haber en alemania un gobierno de
coalición formado por tres partidos y
nosotros los cristianodemócratas hemos
recibido un claro mensaje por parte de
nuestros votantes
un voto para la cdu es un voto contra un
gobierno liderado por la izquierda
[Música]
y nos quedamos con las palabras de la
zet hemos recibido un claro mandato para
generar o conformar un gobierno eso
decía la fe en el momento en que muchos
realmente no lo podían creer cuando ya
se conocía también que la ceoe había
perdió por lo menos 8 puntos es un
atrevimiento de decidir eso hemos
recibido un mandato claro para formar un
gobierno claro se puede y los números
dan podrían formar un gobierno con los
verdes y los liberales pero
tradicionalmente siempre el partido que
recoge más votos es el que inicia las
primeras negociaciones y si ellos
fracasan pues se ven otras opciones
entonces hasta un día antes de las
elecciones muchos cristianos demócratas
decían que si no somos el número uno en
alemania no vamos a formar el gobierno
yo creo que el pueblo alemán le ha dicho
a armin la siedo claramente no te
queremos entonces escuche y eso es una
patada de ahogado no o sea yo formó una
coalición con los verdes y con los
liberales para salvar mi fortuna
política
como primer ministro en renania del
norte-westfalia ahí él tiene un puesto
bueno hace un buen trabajo pero yo creo
que el electorado alemán le ha dicho al
cdu ya no los queremos en el gobierno yo
creo que el cdu debería escuchar las
voces en el facebook que hablan de una
reforma interna recordemos brevemente
buscar por favor que hizo una encuesta
concreta de cuando preguntaron a saludar
a los alemanes que votarían en caso que
fuera una votación directa que no la no
lainer desde luego pero si fuera una
votación directa para escoger a
canciller como que dallas las cuentas
entre entre lo que conocerá 40 por
ciento y más para volar scholtz el
candidato del spd y eran 21 para armin
las 719 paraná línea de la candidata de
los verdes
o sea el voto de los alemanes era
clarísimo y era clarísimo y repito lo
que he dicho inicialmente porque hola
flores representan la continuación del
gobierno merkel la estabilidad
y la socialdemocracia de merkel porque
era muy liberal la paradoja de la
elección y claro en franco todo es todo
bueno o la fuertemente hacía lo propio
no decía lo mismo hemos recibido el
mandato claro del pueblo alemán para
conformar un gobierno y en todo caso con
una con una cifra que le ponía como
vencedor en los comicios
efectivamente sí ya comenzaron las
primeras los primeros sondeos se abre en
primer lugar de una coalición llamada
semáforo es decir el spd junto con los
verdes se juntó con los fdp es algo que
es lo más plausible desde tu punto de
vista y es lo más probable si
seguramente con osea socialdemócratas
verdes y liberales
partiendo de la base que los verdes y
los liberales son los que tienen la
sartén por el mango por eso de alguna
manera porque claro sin ellos dos no hay
forma no hay forma de que se forme otro
gobierno y ellos dos siempre pueden
jugar aunque es cierto coincido con lo
que dice él pero pero es cierto que
existe esa otra chance de una coalición
jamaica que sería la otra con los
democristianos nos podrían hacer un poco
hay de plano y de de jugar ahí al póker
pero sí es cierto que olaf scholz
ha dicho ha mencionado que en primer
lugar quisiera estar con los verdes los
verdes también han manifestado su amor
por la socialdemocracia even false y la
pregunta es si logran seducir a los
liberales y ahí es donde viene el gran
problema no de que se le ofrece a los
liberales cómo se logra un consenso con
los verdes porque ahí hay muchas
discusiones entre sus partidos muchos
puntos que no están realmente cercanos
pero que fracasó en el año 2017 esto
fracasó pero en otra constelación no y
en otro momento es la canciller en ese
momento la que quería ser reelegida era
angela merkel y lo que lo que dicen los
liberales que pasó fue que ellos se
sentían destratado no que que la cdu y
los verdes habían arreglado todo por su
cuenta y ellos venían solamente a portar
los escaños que faltaban ahora si
miramos por la experiencia y me parece
importante en este contexto hay que
mirar un nivel más abajo regional en
alemania donde existen muchos lugares en
alemania donde verdes y
liberales están juntos gobernando con
diferentes formaciones a veces con la
cdu a veces con los socialdemócratas y
funciona
ha logrado porque no sé de acuerdo así
que yo no lo descartaría si quiero saber
qué opina a europa e incluso respecto de
una posible colisión que franco de leona
estima como plausible o la más plausible
spd fdp y los verdes a propósito de lo
que hablamos también de ese gran tarea
que tiene europa y se propone de que en
los próximos años que es el combate
contra el cambio climático si la verdad
es que haber una colisión de este tipo
daría cierta estabilidad pero como
comentábamos hay temas muy importantes
ya no sólo en cambio climático en
economía hay que hablar otra vez de
volver a las reglas fiscales al pacto de
volver otra vez a un 3% máximo de
déficit que alemania lo tiene grabado en
fuego y por lo tanto esto puede ver cómo
puede afectar sin liberales llegan a
tener el ministerio de finanzas las
cosas se pueden poner difíciles en
bruselas en las negociaciones porque
países como españa como italia están
pidiendo que se revuelvan a relajar las
normas después de tener una política
ciertamente expansiva
a cause para atajar las consecuencias
económicas de la banda y esto por
supuesto puede ser bastante complicado
en cambio climático es evidente que si
los verdes se pueden llevar el
ministerio de medio ambiente esto puede
haber grandes avances en materia
climática por ejemplo españa la ministra
de transición ecológica es una de las
más ambiciosas hay un tándem muy
ambicioso españa-alemania por ejemplo o
sea que puede ser muy interesante una
coalición así pero hay que ver porque
como he dicho si va a tardar mucho
europa va a tener que estar paralizado
durante un tiempo y la política sigue
gran pregunta cuánto podría tardar esto
considerando que en 2017 tuvimos que
esperar yo tuvimos que esperar seis
meses para conocerlo yo creo que esta
vez va a ser mucho más rápido yo creo
que la audiencia la que describe esther
está en la mente de los que están
negociando ahora y yo creo que el pp se
muere por gobernar igual que los verdes
ya están hartos estar en la oposición y
el pp la última vez rechazo porque hizo
una mala experiencia cuando gobierno con
el pse llegó en la próxima elección no
entro álbum destaca el parlamento
entonces también se habla del fenómeno
de la viuda negra o sea que la canciller
negra negra de porsche dibuja angela
merkel prácticamente aniquiló al pp
porque no volvió a entrar al parlamento
entonces yo creo que esa experiencia con
el cdu para el pp no fue el mejor para
los liberales por eso yo creo que la
tendencia es va a ser el semáforo con
los verdes tengo una cuestión
existencial a ver el fdp a través de su
jefe de partido desde ayer en nuestra
línea roja son los impuestos y los
verdes y los socialdemócratas
necesitamos más impuestos para pagar la
reforma de clima que está pidiendo
europa entre otras cosas
como
se va a base posible llegar a un punto
de acuerdo en esa cuestión tan
existencial bueno ese es un punto
importante y ahí me voy a permitir poner
un poco de polémica y contradecir al
señor no porque también parece que si
van a durar y justamente en esos puntos
está la razón de por qué pienso que van
a durar espero cuanto a ver para para
pronunciación por exagerado a me gusta
de como mínimo como la última vez como
mínimo seis veces ha de verse y a mí
digamos me parece esto como marcas de
los impuestos es importante y creo que
parece el lugar donde menos encuentro
hay pero al mismo tiempo puede ser el
primer paso hacia hacia acercarse por
ejemplo unos quieren subirlos los otros
quieren bajar otra vez lo dejamos como
están y más o menos podemos llegar a un
punto de acuerdo o tal vez tocamos
impuestos que no ponen el dedo en la
yaga por ejemplo se hablaba de un
impuesto a las ganancias extra no
digamos al dinero que uno tiene y a las
propiedades etcétera fue en brno y eso
es para los liberales intocables pero
aparece por ejemplo el impuesto a la
herencia que tal vez desde la ideología
liberal no que tanto pregona al mérito
etcétera tal vez el impuesto a la
herencia
algo aceptar y se podrían empezar a
buscar pero además de lo de europa que
es muy importante lo del clima también
es un problema en estos entre estos dos
partidos porque los verdes quieren decir
bueno qué vamos a hacer con las
emisiones que tienen que hacer o qué
pueden hacer las empresas y dónde tienen
que reformarse etcétera y los liberales
no dicen el mercado es libre y cada
empresa decide dónde cambio y dónde se
hace más o menos verde ahí también
tenemos problemas pero hay que haber
muchos compromisos y me parece loco y yo
creo que alemania está retirado de lo
nuclear pero yo no excluyo que al final
de una coalición de éstas resulte porque
no vamos a poder cerrar las plantas de
carbón oreja rápidamente que se
prolongue otra vez la duración de las
plantas nucleares con el pp que lo
quieren porque ya están ahí
no se sabe qué hacer con los desechos el
problema está ahí pero prorrogando el
del tiempo de uso podría aliviar un poco
la presión pero yo creo que los
liberales son muy buenos para fomentar
la innovación
de la industria para soluciones
industriales para el clima yo creo que
ahí yo creo que podría haber una
combinación con los verdes que salen muy
buena o sea fomentar inversiones en
nitrógeno o carros con nitrógeno y cosas
así yo creo que los liberales tienen
ideas buenas que se podrían unir a la
idea de claro la modernización del
estado del tema de la digitalización
tonto fars los problemas que confluyen
tanto verdes como liberales y yo quería
destacar algunos e impresiones que les
parece ustedes puede observar esta
elefanta en el mundo de ayer donde todos
los suelos los jefe de los partidos
hablan después de conocerse los
resultados que ya está ahora ya era
irremontables era muy muy lindo ver como
en realidad entre todos tienen ánimos de
llegar a acuerdos y eso realmente en los
tiempos que nos ha tocado vivir de
polarización de los políticos se sacan
los ojos incluso de la campaña que fue
una campaña a veces bastante desleal
funval esta mano sí es cierto es una
buena tradición a mí me gusta de lo
hablábamos antes no de esto de que todos
se sienten y discutan de igual a igual
en términos racionales o posibilitados
pero también es cierto que cuando uno
lee entre línea lo que se fueron
diciendo muchos muchos digamos ataques
indirectos etcétera existe eso y esto a
mí me gusta mucho especialmente porque
es el momento en el cual se muestran lo
más auténtico posible no sé si es porque
recién aparecieron los resultados de las
elecciones y están débiles no pudieron
hacer el coaching tan rápido pero sí que
se ven algunas expresiones no algunos
gestos en la comunicación no verbal por
ejemplo ayer estaban casi todos tristes
esto lo decía mi amigo raúl gil todos
tristes en el sentido de que todos
hubiesen querido otra cosita no y no les
no les terminaba de conformar y eso eso
se ve se ve en ese lenguaje y se ve
también los mensajes no ya que mencionas
a raúl gil una de las cosas que siempre
estaba diciendo en otros programas es
también lo escuchado es brillante a tu
colega raúl y también decía que el
próximo gobierno alemán debería mirar
más hacia américa latina porque era es
la gran tarea tendiente de angela merkel
qué opinan ustedes bueno que usted es
española pero tú conoces bien la
política de angela merkel hacia américa
latina frank o que te digo que podemos
decir de eso
o sea
por ejemplo
las verdes van a ser mucha mucha presión
para la protección de la mala la
amazonía o sea todo todo todo toda la
liberación de liberalización del
comercio se va a ligar a la cuestión
ecológica y de derechos humanos eso fue
lo que anna lenna verbo la cantidad de
los verdes digo queremos una política
exterior que respete los derechos
humanos que tiene en cuenta los derechos
humanos yo creo que eso es algo muy muy
positivo pero desafortunadamente en
general latinoamericano no tiene la
atención que merece desde alemania y
europa yo lo siento mucho pero yo aspiro
a que se produzca un cambio con el
próximo adversario hubo una intención
que también llevó adelante el propio
presidente federal alemán que era el
ministro de relaciones exteriores frank
walter steinmeier respecto un plan de
acción para américa latina basado en
colombia pero también llevó la pandemia
eso también obstaculizó las cosas no sin
pandemia ahora esperemos y pensemos que
las cosas van a ir a mejor con la
pandemia puede pero una política hacia
latinoamérica también pensando en las
riquezas que tienen latinoamérica en una
época de incertidumbre mundial en sus
materias primas en un mercosur por
ejemplo que piense más tanto en la
política extractivista que ha tratado de
impulsar hasta ahora sino más bien en
una en una de cooperación como espera
ante realmente cooperación tecnológica
donde donde los planes se puedan ver por
igual es algo se podría avanzar en un
estrategia es algo que no dependa
alemania solamente es una cuestión
europea no si así es sobre el acuerdo
del mercosur
precisamente el parlamento europeo ya ha
dejado claro que no lo va a ratificar
aunque están en un proceso legal pero el
parlament europeo ya ha dicho que no lo
va a ratificar tal y como está ahora
mismo entonces es evidente que ahora
mismo la situación está muy complicada
luego también las elecciones en francia
el tema de mercosur está muy delicado
también lo es para los franceses por lo
tanto va a ser también un tema candente
y hasta las elecciones francesas mínimo
y hasta que no haya gobierno en alemania
eso va a estar estable al cabo para el
gobierno francés para manuel marco como
lo es para jair bolsonaro en brasil
donde también se hay elecciones y allí
se espera un cambio de gobierno sí claro
8 nada pues está quemando la amazonía es
esto para él también es muy delicado
todo absolutamente y en francia la
lógica de agricultura de los
agricultores muy fuerte aunque la
agricultura en francia solamente
contribuye un 3 por ciento al productor
o producto bruto interno pero la
psicología de la agricultura el valor
psicológico para el pueblo es muy grande
por eso los pescadores y los
agricultores tienen un poder enorme en
francia y ellos van a manifestar contra
cualquier liberalización contra la carne
uruguaya o argentina que llegue barata
en los mercados franceses eso no lo
tienen no estamos hablando de las
elecciones alemanas esto es un programa
especial de a fondo de chévere para para
desmenuzar analizar también en la
colaboración de france24 está nuestra
colega que nos acompaña de bruselas lo
que es lo que ha pasado este día domingo
en una jornada histórica en una jornada
complicada y para muchas veces
sorpresiva una cosa en todo caso parece
clara es que para que haya gobierno en
alemania verdes y liberales van a tener
que poner de acuerdo sí o sí
debería hablar antes entre ellos dicen
algunos para ver si se coaligan con
conservadores o socialdemócratas y
tampoco ahí parece haber entendimiento
claro hasta ahora esto decían anoche los
líderes de esos partidos escuchados
los verdes y el fdp deberían dialogar
primero entre ellos para actuar con
diligencia después
robert huff y yo dejamos claro
anteriormente que este planteamiento no
ayudaría al reforzamiento que
necesitamos para este país
así que lo más sensato es que los
diferentes partidos hablen entre sí para
llegar a posibles alianzas
[Música]
y tú lo decía si tu frase introductoria
work a ciegas ahora el gran dilema o la
gran característica de esta de estas
elecciones es que no serán las dos
principales fuerzas sino los dos
partidos pequeños los que van a decidir
finalmente con tiempo formar gobierno y
tú sin embargo descarta que esa la ceu
si a esos 100 por ciento bueno eso es
una segunda opción claro y es la opción
preferida de los liberales porque hay
mucha coincidencia en políticas no en
estratégicas
estrategias políticas pero a
los verdes se programan los verdes de
los socialdemócratas tienen mucho más en
común no y los verdes son mucho más
fuertes que los liberales o sea yo creo
que eso hace el primer paso pero es
claro es obvio es señal que los dos
pequeños se pongan de acuerdo como lo
han hecho en un slender en unos estados
federales y dicen esos son los puntos
donde podemos imaginar una cooperación
donde nos acercamos y vamos a ver quién
de los grandes o los cristianos
demócratas o los socialdemócratas
el máximo de nuestras ideas y un creo
que que precisamente los puntos de los
cuales hablamos política de impuestos
política fiscal política de medio
ambiente yo creo que esos dos partidos
se tienen que poner de acuerdo para
enfrentar a los grandes yo sea olaf
scholz o amenace dependen completamente
de si los dos se ponen de acuerdo y cómo
se pone de acuerdo es muy interesante
también contarles a quienes nos están
viendo a través de televisión y otra vez
a través de las redes sociales es contar
cuál es el carácter real del partido de
los verdes alemán porque algunos en
américa latina se pueden analizar lo que
no conocen y sitúan a los verdes como un
partido de izquierda no lo es y no lo va
a hacer no en algún momento en sus
inicios tal vez tenían ese ese perfil
ese perfil más de izquierda o más de
antisistema incluso eso se perdió con el
tiempo eso ya no es así de hecho los
líderes anna-lena vox y robben javi que
son los líderes desde 2018 o sea cuando
terminaron las últimas elecciones que
fueron desastre para los verdes salieron
últimos cambiaron la dirección de
partido y ellos son más pragmáticos
ellos tienen bastante diferente incluso
del discurso ellos eliminaron de todos
los papeles del partido palabras clave
que los ponían como los amargados como
estos que prohíben que dicen lo que hay
que hacer que si no haces lo que yo digo
está mal etcétera y ellos lo hicieron un
partido más de centros si quiere y eso
es lo que vimos hoy cuando vemos que los
votos como te decía antes de merkel se
diluyen y se van a otros partidos porque
no quería nada me las jets se van un
poco más a la socialdemocracia pero
también a los verdes y en todas las
elecciones regionales lo vimos también y
lo que me parece interesante de lo que
decía a buscar respecto de estos dos
partidos tercer y cuarto eligiendo al
primero es que en esa ronda de los
elefantes por ejemplo marco es ahora que
es el jefe de la unión social cristiana
dijo expresaba nosotros somos el mejor
partner para estos dos partidos que
quieren el cambio en alemania que
lideran el cambio porque los liberales
quieren no sé digitalización y los
verdes quieren más de eso para luchar
contra la crisis climática y era como
que se estaba vendiendo no como que se
estaba ofreciendo yo soy mejor que él
las jons porque te puedo ofrecer
estabilidad dijo no en algún punto pero
claro es un cambio de roles increíble
que yo no me hubiese imaginado que
pasaría en alemania que los partidos
grandes pasen a ser los que los que
tienen que ofrecer y ofrecer para que
los elijan como tal pero si los verdes
es un partido burgués como como están
delineando francos entonces tampoco se
estaría tan mal que como balística cuál
harán finalmente con la cdu no bueno
ellos gobiernos con la sede de muchos
lugares de hecho en el único lugar donde
los verdes son primera fuerza que sin
embargo también el sur de alemania su
rico donde están las fábricas de autos
donde hay mucha industria etcétera
ahí gobierna los verdes y gobiernan con
la cdu y desde hace tiempo también no no
desde hace más de una legislatura que
están ahí y eso lo han logrado y lo han
conseguido y ha funcionado con lo cual
existe esa conexión se puede dar no sé
si éstos ilustra descarta una coalición
y es que él ya hablaba yo recién quería
también puntualizar que ustedes también
explicar en ese carácter real de los
verdes porque si los verdes está la
certeza de que van a formar el próximo
gobierno para la mayoría de los
observadores también en éste
los verdes con ese carácter de partido
ciudadano por así decirlo hay una cosa
en materia de política exterior que no
quieren negociar y es no quieren más
rusia ellos quieren tener a raya rusia
como sería o como le viene esa esa
característica a la política europea
ahora mismo con todos los problemas que
está teniendo europa respecto a
reducción si bueno lo cierto es que las
relaciones con rusia siempre han sido
muy complicadas pérez desde la
considerada ilegal anexión de la
península de crimea las relaciones se
empezaron a realmente complicar en la
última reunión de líderes de la otan del
pasado junio pero también lo vimos en la
cumbre estados unidos-unión europea
vimos que rusia es una de las cuestiones
principales preocupa mucho rusia los
ciberataques la selección como puede
influir por ejemplo en las las próximas
elecciones en la unión europea sin duda
preocupa para vez es un vecino al que
hay que tener unas relaciones hay que
tener llamadas es evidente que tienes
que mantener una política de mente
contención porque es evidente que lo
tienes aquí al lado entonces
y tienen que tienen que compartir con
rusia pero claro luego está el problema
de los tremendos que esto genera
muchísima incomodidad tanto en la unión
europea como las relaciones entre
alemania y eeuu
veremos a partir de la primavera cuando
el gas empiece a fluir como parece ser
esto es una relación muy complicada la
verdad ente en europa sobre de proyecto
europeo de proyecto alemán de proyecto
alemán claro claro solamente para que no
están viendo ese es el gran gasoducto
que alemany impulso con rusia para
atraer gas ruso a alemania es
determinado costó muchos miles de
millones de euros y todo indica que no
haber marcha atrás no debería haberlo
con la próxima legislatura no ya está
terminado la construcción ya se terminó
y bueno ahora esperamos al gas que
llegue eso es rusia que pasa continua en
que pasa también con el impredecible aún
eeuu y lo pregunto mirando a francia con
el affaire de los submarinos ese
contrato que eeuu se metió en medio con
australia y que dejó las relaciones en
el punto más bajo que habíamos visto
entre el gobierno francés y el gobierno
donde eeuu sí sin duda bueno para
francia en particular y a la unión
europea en general el acordado cause ha
sido una hecatombe porque mantenían una
luna de miel con eeuu que realmente
envuelto como un baño de realidad de
repente la luna de miel se acabó y se
han dado cuenta que claro que después
del terremoto de donald trump igual
combaten las cosas no iban a ser tan
buenas entonces la verdad es que ha sido
bastante complicado es verdad que eeuu
ha intentado hacer gestos hablando con
angela merkel hablando con emanuel
macrón pero sí que es cierto que ahora
ha habido un punto y aparte a las
relaciones con
eeuu y sobre todo francia que incide
mucho en esta autonomía estratégica va a
ser muy interesante cómo puede arrestar
francia en el nuevo gobierno alemán
sobre esta cuestión de la autonomía
estratégica de europa tiene que pensar
más por sí misma pero también hay que
ver cómo porque europa con esta guardado
se dado cuenta que en geopolítica está
buscando una brújula no sabiendo está va
como pollo sin cabeza wow y gran
pregunta que hay que hacer nos hacemos
todos de poder lo que pasó con el
affaire de eeuu y francia puede confiar
europa en eeuu y se puede confiar cuánto
puede confiar después de todo lo que
estás contando bueno lo cierto es que
eeuu incluso donald trump siempre se ha
incidido eeuu sigue siendo un aliado eso
por supuesto pero sí que es cierto que
la unión europea cada vez se está dando
más cuenta de que no puede confiar
eternamente solo en eeuu esto genera
muchas divisiones dentro de la unión
europea a los países del este les
importa mucho el paraguas de seguridad
que ejerce estados unidos con sus
relaciones con rusia por lo tanto es
evidente que esto genere también
divisiones e incomodidades en la norma
crohn está mucho insistiendo con esta
autonomía estratégica con que europa
tiene que más cuidar de sí misma
es cierto que estos niños no va a dejar
de ser un aliado para europa tiene que
buscarse un poco las castañas del fuego
y yo creo que el nuevo gobierno con los
verdes que son muy pro europeos va a
meter el enfoque sobre una unión más
íntima en europa en fortalecer europeo
creo que es muy importante es uno de los
legados negativos de merkel que no ha
respondido a las ofertas y las
propuestas de manuel macro de
intensificar la unión y también el
gobierno que sea tendrá que aumentar
presupuesto de defensa porque si europa
lo hemos visto en afganistán no es capaz
de dar la ayuda de aviones de
portaaviones de todo eso pues siempre
dependerá de eeuu inclusive con badén
hay que ver muy claramente que no es el
solo aliado en que hay que confiar 100%
de europa tiene que asumir un papel más
fuerte en el mundo tiene que unirse más
fuerte y ahí yo creo yo espero que el
nuevo gobierno
retomen las propuestas de macro y
trabaje con el motor franco-alemán otra
vez para promover una europa más intensa
aunque sea un núcleo de países y luego
ya vamos a ver que todos van a unirse a
este núcleo eso sería muy interesante de
ver nos quedan apenas dos minutos del
programa y vuelvo a plantearles a
ustedes al panel en la pregunta con la
que comenzamos este esta emisión
especial de las direcciones de alemania
alemania sin merkel como sigue la
historia quien quiere partir franco de
donde tú dijiste esto
cómo sigue bueno la verdad es que el fin
del área merkel significa
una era nueva en todo sentido en el
político dentro de su propio partido lo
que marcaba empuja en el sentido de
dónde va a ir su partido se va a ir más
a la derecha se va a quedar ahí en el
centro esto significa también para la
unión europea pensar que va o qué rol va
a ocupar alemania a través del líder que
tenga posiblemente volar shorts pero no
lo sabemos cómo va a ser el impacto de
las políticas verdes en encendido
entonces creo que es una era
absolutamente nueva y estoy muy ansioso
de ver qué pasó un minuto antes de
terminar el programa estar por favor
deseo en la palabra como si la historia
yo creo que es momento de que alemania
sea esa potencia transformadora que
comer que él no fue merkel al final fue
una buena gestora pero no una persona
que daba una transformación el gran
salto entonces yo creo que ahora debe
ser el momento
walker ver que generamos el cohete para
la innovación hacia una nación
industrial ecológica muy bien porque al
ver que el franco delle donne esterero
muchas gracias por estar ahí esta
edición el trasfondo para ustedes en
estas elecciones de alemania 2021 si
bien y pérez muchas gracias y hasta
pronto
[Música]